My name is Anni Beukes. I'm a fellow the
Mansueto Institute for urban
Innovation at the University of Chicago.
I've just joined the Institute after
spending almost five years that Slum Dwellers International at Secretariat
in Cape Town my research in my work both
in research and practice is really
around the connection or the
intersection between poverty, politics, and
place and I try to work with
communities and support their visions around
how they think and imagine there are
settlements to be. At the core in the
talk that I gave today was to to share
with students some of the challenges of
urbanization in sub-saharan Africa
what these challenges would mean both in
terms of physical infrastructure but
also rapid social change that we are
seeing I'm very excited about the youth
of Africa because that's we have the
biggest youth population in sub-saharan
Africa and that for me really is the
core of what is going to drive
sustainable and equitable development
when we pay attention to what it is that
young people imagine, what they aspire to,
and create the kinds of environments
that will give them a space from which
to launch their biggest dreams for our
planet and for their own well-being
and prosperity.